everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're gonna be
looking at game 18 from the 1972 World
Chess Championship between Bobby Fischer
and Buddhi Spassky Bobby Fischer coming
into this round has a three point
advantage over his opponents and it
seems like he's been content withdrawals
over the past few games he's had some
winning positions he's converted those
into drawls and he seems okay with that
so coming into game 18 it'll be
interesting to see his approach with the
white pieces very quickly he could be
putting a nail in the coffin if he gets
a few wins here but but he's fast he
playing the black pieces we'll look to
try to get something going he hasn't won
a game in quite some time now in this
series but we're gonna get started Bobby
Fischer plays pawn to e4 his favorite
opening and chess pawn to c5 so the
Sicilian defense Knights f3 pawn d6
Knight c3 knight c6 oh goody ensued the
classical variation pawn d4 pawn
captures Knight d4 and then Knight to f6
there's a few ways that Bobby Fischer
can play this Bishop here to g5 or if
you wanted to Bishop to c4 we've talked
about before many times when your
opponent plays pawn to d6 you can bring
your Bishop out here to c4 attack these
light squares they still may play pawn
to e6 or e5 sometimes you even wait for
them to play pawn to e5 so that there is
no protection on these light squares
Bobby Fischer decides to go ahead and
play Bishop here to g5 getting your dart
square out outside of the pawn chain
pinning down this knight if this pawn
ever moves and we see buddy's baski play
pawn to e6 he wants to open up for the
Queen to protect this night here on f6
it's always awkward if nothing's
protecting and the bishop takes and you
have to take away from the center of the
board or even worse would be to take
with your pawn right here just loses
protection for your King now if you look
at and say well why isn't it better just
for the white to core this pawn to come
down here to e5 this not only opens up
the door for the Queen to defend this
Knight but it also attacks the knight
well it just gets awkward after the
bishop takes and then if the Queen
to take back here because we were to
talk about how awkward it is if you take
with this pawn then the knight coming up
to d5 is a strong attack that black just
doesn't want to have to deal with
attacking the Queen also threatening the
knight up here to c7 yes this Knight is
under attack but anytime white once - we
can just exchange up here on c6 so not a
variation that black wants to go down if
you are playing this is white in the the
classical variation and you see this
just be aware of some of the options
that you have from White's perspective
so we see Bishop up here to g5 and then
just pawn to e6 Queen here - D - just
signaling that hey I can castle on the
Queen side or can still get this light
squared bishop involved into the game
and castle on the King side as well pawn
to a6 this is more of a move we see a
lot in the the Sicilian offense similar
one of the variations the NIE Dorf
defense that starts out very early but
this stops both the Knights coming up
here to b5 it also starts for a
preparation for attack on the Queen side
knowing that Bobby Fischer may be
castling on the Queen side this does set
up for a potential attack from black on
the queenside castle on the Queen side
Bishop to d7 get involved into the game
and then pawn up here to f4 so usually
what's gonna happen is once you casts on
one side of the board you start to just
throw everything in the kitchen sink at
your opponent on the other side of the
board you don't have to worry too much
usually you're not gonna be playing your
pawns very forward in the game because
you don't want a lot of air in front of
your your own King but since there is no
King on the King side then a lot of
pawns pushing up here so pawn to f4 this
isn't also outpost for the bishop here
on g5 Bishop to e7 and the knight comes
back here to f3 and this is a nice move
if you look at the setup and see this
Bishop on e7 it was back here on FA just
protecting this pawn now it comes to e7
it's protecting both the pawn and the
night here on f6 but okay this Bishop is
doing double duty and any time a piece
from your opponent is playing double
duty you need to start to attack that
particular piece or one of the pieces
that's protecting and that's exactly
what Bobby Fischer does you play
night back here to f3 now the queen is
attacking this pawn and the Bishop is
attacking this Knight this bishops
playing double duty so you know if this
bishop were to take right here then
blacks gonna have a hard time trying to
defend this square you could always
retake with this pawn right here so he
could be play a move which I think would
be the optimal move her buddies Basking
this Queen to c7 it relieves some of the
pressure from this bishop on e7 doesn't
have to defend both of these squares but
instead he plays pawn down here to b5
which makes sense just from a somatic
standpoint of what black wants to do but
in this position it it's not as good
because now Bishop takes on f6 the
bishop can't take care on f6 we already
talked about it it's bad because it
loses material here on d6 which is what
Bob Fisher was coming for and so black
has forced to take with this pawn here
on f6 probably not gonna be castling on
the Kings side Bobby Fischer has a set
up to attack here on the Kings side and
last thing you want to do is castle
where you don't have a lot of protection
so this King looks to be saying in the
center of the board for the rest of the
game Bobby Fischer continues with Bishop
up here tube d3 then Queen down to a5
attacking this pawn here on a tube and
this is another nice little thing that
buddy Spassky is trying to do which
Bobby Fischer is very aware of this but
as you're looking in your own game you
can see that this pawn right here can
easily come to b4 and it's hacked this
night this Knights forced to move and so
what piece or square is this Knight
defending it's defending the square here
on a tube so birdy Spassky comes down to
a 5 and a lot of players would look at
this and say okay my my pawn here on a2
is protected I don't have to worry about
it but if Y it's not too careful then
just pawn to b4 forcing the knight to
move and then the pawn is going to fall
so Bobby Fischer plays King to b1 to
make sure he can protect this pawn here
on a2 because the next move and that's
exactly what Bob or buddy Spassky does
plays pawn to b4 forcing the knight to
come back here to e2 Queen d c5 just
centralizing trying to have an attacking
position from Spassky pawn up here to F
I've pawned down to a five Knight to f4
pawn down to a four so just pushing on
the Queen side of the board rook over
here to c1 rook to b8 of both sides just
maneuvering a little bit pawn to c3 pawn
down here to b3 and this is an
interesting position where buddy Spassky
has an option to start blowing up some
of the pawns here on the Queen side of
the board instead he opts for a
different approach pawn to b3 Bobby
Fischer I would imagine played this
pretty quickly but pawn to a3 and this
actually solidifies the pawn chain in
front of the White King making it pretty
safe for Bobby Fischer so interesting to
see how buddy Spassky did not want to
exchange some of the material here on
the Queen side potentially had a
stronger attack later in the game but
instead decided for block heating those
pawns right here Knight to e5 and this
is a position where Bobby Fischer has to
make sure he plays pretty carefully here
both of his Knights are in the center of
the board
so Bobby Fischer has good control of the
center if you were to take right here
this would be a mistake we could see the
knight take here on e5 the pawn takes
here on e5 now all of a sudden this has
opened up this D file for the rook to
get involved and really control this
where before Bobby Fischer can control
with the semi open file since he doesn't
have any pawns blocking his rooks he can
come over here to d1 this also forces
the knight to move so Knight over here
to h5 probably doesn't want to come back
here to e2 can't come here to g2 so h5
it's just sort of awkward and now all of
a sudden in a couple moves black has
completely controlled the center of the
board so while it may look like a fair
trade I'll just go ahead and exchange
these Knights off the board definitely
something Bobby Fischer is not looking
to do instead he plays rook to f1 now
Knight over here to see for attacking
the Queen Bishop takes exchanging Queen
takes here on a c4 and then rook to e1
so buddy Spassky does have the bishop
hair which is good but it tends to fare
better in open games and by that I mean
not a lot of material in the center of
the board especially pawns blocking off
the squares where can go to Knights tend
to fare better in these type of games so
all in all Bobby Fischer def
has the upper hand right now in this
position but he Spassky moves King to a
d8 I think he had another option of rook
here to g8 you want to get your rooks
involved to open files where they can
really attack this is a semi open file
where the rooks gonna be putting a lot
of pressure on this g2 square you always
want to come down to your opponent's
second rank if you're the black pieces
not something he can take right now
because both the night in the Queen are
defending it but just another thing that
Bobby Fischer has to think about as he's
trying to formulate a game plan but we
see black play King to d8 King back here
to a1 rope down to b5 so trying to be
aggressive and get more pieces involved
in to the game Knight to d4 rook over
here to a five-night down here to d3
King c7 so it looks like buddy Spassky
is actually looking to get all his
material over to the Queen side of the
board with King to c7 bringing his rook
over here really start to see if he can
chip away this is gonna be difficult
because of the blockade from the pawns I
think this may have worked if he traded
off earlier he can just overwhelm his
opponent with mints hero the knight here
to b4 pawn down to h5 upon a g3 rook to
e5 and the knight back here to a d3
attacking this rook now I was expecting
for the rook to just come back maybe
have a repetition here and then but a
Spassky chooses to do something else
instead we see rook to b8 just saying
hey if you want to take this rook here
on e5 go ahead and do that Bobby Fischer
got a little tricky and instead of just
taking it played Queen to e2 looking for
a knight moves and then it's also
attacking the Queen here on c4 I don't
think he needed to be that tricky he has
the option of just taking here on e5 if
he wants to that's gonna be completely
fun I think he probably should have done
that but in the game played Queen to e2
rook back here to a5 pawn takes on e6
pawn recaptures rook here to F 2 and
then pond down here to e5 forcing the
knight to move Knight comes up here
- f5 we do stand exchange the rook comes
to f5 this is gonna be a tricky square
for black to ever remove this rook from
and not only is it an outpost you can
always remove an outpost by attacking
the pawn here on e4
but because black doesn't have a
LightSquared bishop also doesn't have a
knight to kick this off this is gonna be
a pain in black side for as long as
Bobby Fischer wants it to be now we see
pawn down to d5 the pawn takes and then
the Queen recaptures here on d5 and this
is a position where I think Betty
Spassky overlooked a huge attack that
Bobby Fischer has and that's pawn to c4
now Bobby Fischer did not play that in
the game he played night two before
opening up the door for the Queen to
attack these light squares attacking the
Queen right here but ponta to c4 makes a
lot of sense the reason is the Queen
can't take here on c4 just rook to c1
it's protected by the knight and this is
pinning down the Queen the Queen is
going to fall in this position so
definitely not a good thing for black
here and you know if for some reason the
Queen comes back let's say queen to c6
and then the rook takes here on h5 and
then depending on where black goes just
the rooks are gonna come up to the
seventh rank you always want to be on
your opponent's seventh rank get behind
enemy lines start to attack this pin
down to Bishop so we can see where these
baski play rook to d7 but now blacks in
defense mode white is behind enemy lines
he can start to maneuvers other pieces I
think this is a really good position
from white but in the game I decided not
to play pawn up here to c4 and said
plays Knight to B form so Queen comes
back to d7 rook takes on h5 Bishop takes
and says let's go ahead and exchange the
white is up in material but he does have
you know these three pawns over here
it's gonna be tough to materialize any
of those this pawn pushes forward he's
gonna be by himself so all in all both
sides are fairly equal in at the game
rook over here to d5 rook to c1 check
King to b7 that pretty safe King here on
b7
Queen to e
for pinning down this rook rook to c8
rook to b1 and now Bobby Fischer as
we've seen in the past seems to have
gone into a I just need to draw mindset
this rook on b1 is just playing
completely defensive now it's not
involved into the attack when your
opponent has a queen in two rooks it's
gonna be very difficult to do much with
just a queen and a rook in the attack mo
so Bobby Fischer knows it's gonna be
tougher his opponents ever attack him
since his King is so safe but seems to
have resigned the fact of going for win
himself so King to b6 rook to h7 is
protected by the Queen here so just
attacking both sides are gonna just go
back and forth maneuvering around the
board singing if either side is going to
make a mistake but very easier for both
sides to defend all of their pieces
their pawns on the board because they do
have all of their major pieces in the
game and so eventually they have a
threefold repetition and after 47 moves
they have a draw so Bobby Fischer I kind
of feel like it's the congratulations
because this is exactly what he wanted
to happen
he holds a three-point advantage it's
gonna be very difficult for him to lose
three points in this series just because
he's completely dominating his opponent
but he Spassky hasn't won in many many
games so exciting game always fun to see
different variations in the Sicilian
defense we don't see the classical
variation all that often anymore I felt
like the 9th or if even some of the
dragon variations seem or the high-level
play so the classical always nice to to
analyze it and see different positions
and how you know you can apply that to
your own games hopefully you guys
enjoyed watching game 18 from the 1972
World Chess Championship until next time
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
game 19